- I'm so excited 'cause we're
gonna do hoecakes today.
- We are.
- Which I am a huge fan of.
- Oh, same. I love corn so much.
- I love corn.
- So much corn.
I want, I find ways to put
corn in whatever I can.
So, it's such an important thing.
It actually is indigenous
to North America,
which is so great about it.
(audience claps)
- Really?
- Yeah.
Yeah, Native Americans.
Actually, there's a really funny story
about the origin of like a
johnny cake or a hoe cake,
which is what we're making.
- Yeah.
- So like, food historians
are kind of like
all over the place about
what exact tribe created
this thing we know as a johnny cake.
But it was probably the Shawnee Indians,
and the Shawnee Native Americans,
and basically, the
English settlers came in,
and they are basically mispronouncing it.
So it's supposed to be
called a Shawnee cake,
but they heard johnny cake.
So that's where that term comes from.
- And how did hoecake come out of that?
- So hoe cake was, so enslaved folks,
when they were brought here 400 years ago,
they only had access to
cornmeal, water, salt.
They didn't have heating elements.
So they would actually have to make these,
which is why they're this
shape on the bottom of a hoe,
of a farming tool, 'cause
that's all they had access to.
So they would heat their farming tools,
and they would make their little hoecakes.
And that's why they're so small.
Later on, in the 18th and 19th century,
what we now know today as a griddle,
they called a hoe.
So now.
- Understood.
The hoe is the hoe.
- Literally.
(audience clapping)
Aren't these origin stories amazing?
- [Drew] That's what I love about them.
Okay.
- Let's do it.
- Well, I'm excited.
Teach me.
- Wet ingredients.
So just whisk those up.
Yep, whisk 'em up.
(whisk clinking)
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
And as you whisk, I'm gonna do this.
Oh my gosh.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I've like, Martha Stewart
gave me like so much guff
about my whisking game.
So now I'm like, ah.
- No. Martha?
Tell Martha to calm down a little bit.
(audience laughs)
- Martha does love to.
- I love you Martha,
(audience clapping)
but you know.
- Okay.
- I just told Martha
Stewart to calm down on TV.
- She's gonna love it.
- No, she's not. (laughs)
- But that's what I love about her.
She's so tough.
- She's so intense.
- I know, like, she scares me
in the best way ever.
It's like I'm scared and turned on.
I'm so confused.
- I saw her scold Christina Tosi one time.
- Yeah, no, she does.
- It was intense.
- I kind of weirdly,
sickly like it though.
- So like you, what you wanna do with this
is you wanna pour that
in as you're whisking
so you create emulsification.
So this is nice and.
- Exactly. Emulsify.
- So then you're gonna take that.
You see we also have this
bowl with the pourer.
- I love a spout.
- Don't you love it?
Right into the center.
See now, I'm gonna whisk too.
- Okay whisk.
And I'm gonna.
- Yes, keep whisking.
Yes, I'm gonna keep whisking.
And you're gonna pour.
Once you get this all incorporated,
it's actually really good
to let your batters rest
for at least 30 minutes.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, it's really good to let
those glutens kind of relax.
- Let it rest.
- So then.
- Understood.
- So then, also see how thick it is?
- So it's 20, 30 minutes later.
- Yes. Pretend.
So we got some oil in the pan.
But you see, look what
ha, look how different.
- Yeah, it's much thicker.
- Right? That's good.
That's a good thing.
Yeah. Yeah.
(audience claps)
This is really hot.
I'm worried.
- Is it too hot?
- I don't know. Let's see, let's see.
Maybe it's not.
(griddle sizzles)
Let's see. Maybe it's not.
- I don't wanna turn it
down too much 'cause then
you'll have no heat.
- No, it's good.
It's good. It's good.
(hoecake sizzles)
- [Drew] Oh, that looks so good.
- Yeah, right?
And so what we're gonna, we
have over here is some butter.
'Cause we're gonna make a special syrup
because why do a basic one
when you can do a special one?
You come over here and whisk this.
So you whisk this.
So we have honey and maple syrup
because honey is more for flavor.
Maple syrup is more for texture.
- [Drew] Okay.
- [Sophia] So the more,
when you mix sweeteners,
you get depth, which
is really, really nice.
Because people think, oh,
what's the difference, honey, maple?
They really do taste different
and have completely different textures.
- [Drew] How am I doing over here?
- You're doing so, but it's like perfect.
But you see how we're
doing it on the stove top?
- [Drew] Yeah.
- it's so, I really think heating
your whatever you're gonna put on top,
whether it's butter,
heating it beforehand,
and just letting it
kind of hang out there.
It's almost like a glaze.
You know what I'm saying?
- I do.
- So we're gonna do this.
But see we're already
set up over here, Drew.
So like we're already good.
So what I'm gonna do, do we have a spoon?
- Yeah.
- Let's take a spoon.
- So like, what we can
do is we can actually,
like literally, we can just go like this.
Stop it.
- That's a slotted spoon.
- Do you see? Like what?
(audience clapping)
- [Drew] I was trying to
get you a bigger spoon.
- No, I'm into the little spoon.
- Okay.
- I like a little baby spoon.
- Do you see me?
I'm like (heavy breathing)
- Come over here.
Here, I'm gonna give this to you.
- I'm like a dog with a bone.
- But it's so good.
I'm so, and like do you hear a crispiness?
(fork tapping)
- Yeah. Listen.
Hold on.
(fork tapping)
- Also like, am I want,
can I be like this?
Can I do this?
- Yes.
- Mmm.
- Oh my God.
And this spice, come on.
(audience clapping)
Isn't this so good?
Isn't it so good?
- The outside has this very nice,
- It's so crispy.
- like crust almost texture,
but it's not hard.
- Yes.
- It's still soft.
And then the inside is really airy.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
- Catch new episodes of "Counter Space"
on the Tastemade streaming channel.
And up next, do you
want the star treatment
for half the price in Los Angeles?
Well, our travel guide,
Vegas Starfish, is here.
And I'm from LA, and
I saw her suggestions,
and I was like, yes.
Don't go anywhere.
(lively music)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)